♪ ♪ ♪dans le Marché By d'Ottawa,
tous les moyens sont bons
pour entrevoir, ne serait-ce
qu'un tout petit peu,
celui qui portera un jour
(brouhaha)
- On n'a pas vu grand-chose,
mais juste au loin, on a vu
c'est quand même une célébrité.
- Certains ont attendu
des heures pour deux secondes
de proximité avec la royauté.
(brouhaha)
- Very privileged to be able
kekekeke the Royal's hand.
- Dans la foule,
Félix essaie de se faufiler,
se rapprocher de son idole.
- J'ai le coeur qui bat
très fort. C'est... un moment
très important pour moi.
- Certains ont eu plus
de chance et partagent
ce momeneueueueueurs proches.
- Oui, moi, je lui ai parlé.
- Il lui a demandé comment
ltltltltltltltltltltltltltltltl!
(rires)
Je suis contente, dans le sens
que c'est une personne pop
mais pas plus que ça, là.
♪ (cornemuse)
- Une cérémonie pour honorer
les anciens combattants
Canadiens, une visite
à la communauté ukrainienne,
des élèves choyés
Une visite royale,
alors que le sen
envers la monarchie
semble se refroidir.
Un Canadien sur deux
croit qu'il faut abandonner
Au Québec, c'est presque
trois personnes sur quatre.
- Je trouve ça vraiment
un affront à la démocratieeseses
d'outre-mer, ça.
(rires)
SHACHI KURL,
présidente d'Angus Reid
sont... euh... démodées.
- Dans la foule, le fossé dess .
- Veut, veut pas, il va
. . . . . . roi. Comme ça,
pour mon petit-fils aussi,
je trouve que c'est quelque
chose d'intéressant.
- Mais lui ne semble pas
convaincu.rorororororororororor,
c'est pas aussi excitant
pour m
- La reine Elizabeth II
conserve la c
à égalité avec son petit-fils
William,
Mais le prince Charles
reste le mal-aimé, avec 29 %.
- Quand ça va être sa cha
de prendre le trône,
il va bien faire ça.
- Mais c'est pour ça
qu'il soit connu; il vatotototor
gagner le coeur des Canadiens,
une poignée de main à la fois.aw